pardon you're stronger Denise Diana
again
[Music]
never let your guard down you expect the
battles will be fair how about the ones
never be fair my name is Captain Steve
Trevor pilot American Expeditionary
Forces hero number eight one four one
nine two one that's all that they're
ready to assign the British intelligence
what the hell is this thing the last two
of Hestia compels you to reveal the
truth don't really I what if your
mission whoever you are you are in more
danger than you think what is your
mission
I am spy from the spy spy please slow
down
yes your leader how can you say that
believe that and you with your duty to
simply give them a book you didn't send
your ground you didn't fight just was
you're just changing it with it's an
Aries and he's not going to allow a
negotiation or a surrender the millions
of people you talked about they will die
right win anyway you mean you were lying
fish pie that's what I do I know you're
not lying to me right now I am taking
you to the front idea for the horse
[Music]
stay here I'll go ahead
Hey
[Music]
what the surprise
stretch unfortunately I have another
matter to attend to
what are you you will soon find out
well
as magnificent as you are you are still
no match for me whole lot of new wonder
woman badassery drop in let's break it
down and there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video when we get closer
to it actually coming out in theaters
I'll do it for movie gift certificates
but I'm actually seeing the movie in the
next couple days
so whenever the embargo lifts I will do
my non-spoilery review in a lot of
you've been asking me about like all the
critical response saying it's the best
DC movie so far so I'll address that a
little bit at the end of the video but
nobody in the world has actually been
allowed to post their full review yet so
really what you're reading is hot takes
like people step out of the movie
theater and they're like here's a couple
bullet points this is what I thought but
you just get to see her in action the
fight scenes were always one of the best
things about her character even back in
Batman V Superman because that's really
all she had to do they have a couple
scenes with Batman just a few things to
fill out her backstory before she
decided to join the fight again and just
to be clear like this is happening about
a hundred years after what's happening
here during the Wonder Woman movie so
there will be actual connective tissue
that will tie this to what's happening
in Batman V Superman and then what's
happening next in Justice League just to
place it in the timeline I love what a
badass Robin Wright 10 is in this movie
you see her in something like house of
cards amazing performance you would not
look at her in this and think okay this
is probably somebody who could swing a
sword around and just put people on
their asses but she had some of the best
battle scenes in this movie she's a big
part of training Wonder Woman this is
sort of the culmination of her training
as she's learning about the gauntlets
all the special artifacts most of her
training just happens with normal
weapons until you start seeing her
double team the other Amazons here but
you get some great comedy with the lasso
of truth so it's actually a very
powerful thing she uses it in really
amazing ways those are some of the best
fights towards the climax of the movie
but there's so many funny moments to be
had when someone is unable to tell alive
you see that first clip with Chris Pine
trying to resist it it just slowly wears
him down until it looks like his head is
going to explode with the truth then
later he uses it on himself and they
give Ares a shout out
so that actually clarifies a little bit
about what's going on with Wonder Woman
in Ares in the movie because when
they're having this scene here it
doesn't seem like she knows who he is
but in the movie he's just credited is a
British Lord who's working with the
British prime minister so when she is
complaining about Chris Pine not
changing his mind she's talking about
the British prime minister just drinking
whatever kool-aid that Ares is giving
him in those last fight scenes are
amazing but they're just bigger versions
of scenes that you've seen before in the
trailers the warehouse scene where she
busts in takes out all these Austrian
soldiers smashes the gun on her back
because second clip is against Danny
Huston this is really interesting
because I'm 99.9% sure that he is not
Ares in the movie but he looks super
powerful when he's fighting her so
there's got to be something special
about his character because otherwise he
would not be able to go toe-to-toe with
Wonder Woman look at her pick up this
soldier here jump forward throw him into
someone else that's how strong she is
she even stood her ground for a little
while against doomsday so he's able to
put her on her back it just makes me
wonder if he's got something special
some pact with Ares that's giving him
some secret power but you see her catch
the sword there the reason she's able to
do that without it cutting her 1 she's
extra strong but holding a sword like
that would still cut her up it's just
that her gloves cover part of her hand
so that's what's wrapping around the
blade you just can't see it really well
here but let me know what you think
about all this some of the footage here
is also kind of tuned down it's way
brighter when you go see it in a movie
theater so just to address all the love
that critics are giving us you know so
most of the credit goes to patty Jenkins
the director for her vision Geoff Johns
for sort of helping write the creative
ship a little bit and then you might be
surprised to learn the Zack Snyder did
have some involvement with Wonder Woman
so he sort of came up with the
conception of the character in Batman V
Superman this is a continuation of that
he helped produce the film
he's credit
did on the script but I don't know how
much of the final version of the script
belongs to him because just because
people get credits on films doesn't
necessarily fully reflect the final
version of the film like Geoff Johns
isn't credited as a screenwriter even
though he helped do a lot of work on
Wonder Woman but when people talk about
them course-correcting the DC EU after
the reaction to Batman V Superman and
Suicide Squad
Wonder Woman being the best new example
of that in Justice League also flowing
from a lot of that energy what they
explained is is that a lot of this
really awesome stuff that's happening
that everybody's responding to so well
they were already in the process of
doing especially with justice Lee is
just that after the reaction to the
movies last year they sped up how fast
you get to the really fun stuff in
Justice League
so you'd be relieved to know that this
is always their plan it's just that they
sped the plan up after people were like
hey what's going on here so I think
you'll pleasantly be blown away by
Wonder Woman a lot of action a lot of
heart a lot of heroics a lot of
badassery but it still finds a way to be
hardcore so make sure you guys go check
it out when you have the opportunity but
congratulations to Michael thirtle
you're the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here for brand new
Deathstroke arrow footage and you can
click here for brand new flash footage
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight